what up gamers it's me your boy pogchamp
and i'm kevin and today we're drawing
90s characters from memory from our
brain our little memories i was born in
the 90s but i don't remember it you had
to be there I was there I was little
baby I was 21
yikes your character oh there you go I
have his head in my head but I don't
have his body in your head who from
Rugrats Oh his last name is Finster ah I
would bully that kid Jason what shape is
Arnold's head it is obviously football
head nice yeah I know who Dexter is so
I'm happy I'm just trying to remember
all the details that make Dexter Dexter
he's a kid so he's got a big head they
got huge brains yeah let's not go that
far now I'm like forgetting his face his
eyes okay so Arnold's like the chill
dude so his eyes are always kind of like
he's got his lids closed like halfway
Nicktoons was always they always had
like the cooler um cartoons Nicktoons
had like ah real monsters and Rugrats
which felt safer always had like adult
jokes and they're hidden in there
somewhere yeah you know I didn't watch a
lot of Rugrats but the Rugrats that I
did watch I remember not liking his
character cuz he's like he's like whiny
right yeah he's like the worst Rugrats
character what was great about hey
Arnold for me is that Hey Arnold took
place in like a city yeah I was born and
raised in the in the Bronx yeah and it
was it was great to see a show that
reflected that I reflected that so the
city that's in Hey Arnold is actually a
mix between New York and Seattle which I
thought was super cool so you didn't
watch red dress I watched some of it I
don't really remember it I
watch Dexter a lot as a kid yeah I used
to watch it a lot when I was younger I
would say not as a kid because I mean I
was kind of in high school and getting
into college from Dexter was coming out
Rugrats and like Ren and Stimpy was like
the end of my my nicktoons watching and
then you discovered girls you got a live
life without any shame everybody knows
why incognito mode exists
wait what you know it's funny you never
remember what the feet look like a lot
of the time his boots are hard I don't
like I remember them but I don't think
I'm getting the shape quite right
doesn't even wear like big chunky shoes
chunky Finster
am i right ladies we opened the door on
let some of these puns out one thing
that I remember very distinctly about
Dexter is he is like super square the
character designs on Rugrats were like
super freaky yeah like they were vaguely
unsettling I think it was probably a
product of its time things just didn't
look right it was like that the era of
squiggle vision yeah I don't know I just
pretended like dr. Katz anyone squiggle
vision home movies a thing that I've
struggled with a lot on here is
remembering the small details of
characters clothes I'm totally making
his clothes up right now I think he's
wearing like a flannel shirt underneath
the eye I remember flannel he has
something on his shirt is it a dinosaur
dinosaur shirt his shirts blue I think
oh what color was his hat that's like a
dark blue his hats red oh and his hair
do you remember anything about his hair
he's got blond hair yeah he's yeah he's
got like big frizzy hair right he has
like big orange hair he's got like you
know when you're drawing something poofy
and it has like that little circle in
the middle of like where the tears are
or it's like oh yeah little loops I
don't know what I'm going
I think I'm mixing up Chucky and the
aliens from Toy Story the aliens from
Toy Story have like three eyes and are
green
Chuckie Finster is a human child is he
though yes I remember actually asking my
mom when I was a kid what accent Dexter
had and she said that it was a made-up
one but I think you think it's supposed
to be like Transylvanian right GG's look
at this Vika I'm in some French okay oh
my god I can't wait to see yours I know
I can't wait to see you too my final
touches is this cigarette and making his
eyes kind of red because it's high so
Jason we feeling more confident about
this one um yeah I I know it looks like
Arnold it's okay
he's you know I think it's getting
closer to what he probably looks like I
think I'm doing I gotta stop fiddling
with it
just leave it I think I did okay I think
I got a lot of the details wrong I'm
pretty sure the color of his shirt and
his diaper I put him in a diaper he may
be wearing shorts it's Arnold he's an
adult and he's had a hard life
oh that's so good oh girl oh my god oh
yeah this Arnold's chill is head why
this diaper purple though so I don't
know I feel like he needed a purple
diaper I loved his expression you nailed
the character like that's totally that's
totally I'm jealous
you're the body of your Arnold's feels
like the real character design yeah you
gave him like him like a human body
straight-up Anatomy are you disappointed
in me
I just thought it's good Kevin just why
wouldn't you I immediately make the
diaper white I did the diaper purple and
as soon as I did that I was like he's
probably wearing shorts yeah I think
your brain is mixing up concepts yep you
know I love yours no I think it's great
thanks I'm not gonna lie to you though I
don't think it's very on model maybe
that's true but I tried my bad you did
try your best you got the dinosaur and
like I said it's not on model but it is
very cute and you were right about yours
it being vaguely unsettling vaguely
unsettling I think I'm more disturbed by
the diapers than anything oh oh no wait
that was blue okay wait I feel like I
remember his hat being now maybe it was
blue I was I did remember a lot of
things yeah I somehow remembered that
his nose was point even though I started
drawing it round you did too yeah I got
the pointy nose and you got the gloves
you got the gloves and the boots the
boots you got the boot I sorta got the
boots did I give him shoes in my drawing
you did you gave him a little purple
shoes okay yours
yours is actually like really close like
it's just if Chucky was pants
your design is spot-on except for the
different color of the the feet yeah
early it yeah yeah pretty great aren't I
okay so here's the thing there was
something on his shirt but it's a planet
not a dinosaur we both got the glasses
correct though yeah
and you got the eye style right in that
it's just the glasses with the pupils in
it yeah I think it's it's it's simple
but it's deceptively simple in that
you've got to get all those details
right or else it's not Dexter I think we
did pretty good for two people who
didn't really watch Rugrats nobody can
tell us that we did bad except for the
Internet
[Music]